[Musique]
charles reçoit un appel son répondeur
démarre et il se trouve a enregistré la
conversation une entreprise vous offre
un forfait internet télévision téléphone
à un prix vraiment alléchant charles
accepte de s'abonner
mais la facture qu'il reçoit par la
suite ne correspond pas du tout aux
belles promesses qu'on lui a faite il
téléphone à l'entreprise pour réclamer
qu'elle respecte ses promesses et il dit
qu'il a des preuves enregistrées la
préposée au bout du fil lui répond que
cet enregistrement est illégale at elle
raison non charles à participer à la
conversation téléphonique
il avait donc tout à fait le droit de
l'enregistrer il peut même se servir de
cet enregistrement en cours car c'est un
élément qui contribue à établir la
vérité
le fin mot de l'histoire contre les
tromperies des commerçants
l'enregistrement est une arme redoutable
est parfaitement légal